govenor sisal ACK addressed the state
today saying we're just not ready for
Phase three of reopening we need a
little bit more time to verify the
impact of these recent openings an
Oracle mana now joining us live from the
strip tonight to share the governor's
message
orco well Brian Indonesia we've been in
Phase two for a couple of weeks now but
because of a rising Cova 19 cases and
hospitalizations the governor says we
are not ready to move on to Phase three
we're not in the post over time we're in
the middle of a covert nineteen pandemic
we're right dead smack in the middle of
it a strong statement from governor
Steve Sicily as Nevada stays in Phase
two that means no additional
restrictions are being lifted we don't
want to go forward and then take a step
backward as the state reopens and more
testing is available we're seeing an
uptick in Cova 19 cases as predicted
there's been an upward trend over the
last three weeks and a consistent
increase in hospitalization since June
5th before expanding our reopening and
entering a phase three we must continue
to allow ourselves the time to evaluate
this new medical information with large
crowds forming on the strip in downtown
contact tracing will help figure out how
people are contracting the virus for
example in the casinos or at the recent
protests in both cases there's little
social distancing and sometimes minimal
mask use now is not the time to abandon
these protective measures it is a time
to double down on them we can only stay
open if we stay safe Las Vegas we talk
to our torn on the idea of waiting the
governor's team I think are trying to do
what's best but I also think there are
some long-term effects to keeping things
shut down I feel like things do need to
progress and they need to move forward
either way but I also understand staying
in Phase two just a little bit longer
governor Sissel act says science will
make the final say the virus is what
drives the timeline
again governor says alack has not set a
date yet for phase three for a
perspective phase one lasted for about
three weeks and phase two we are
currently just over two weeks into phase
two reporting live near the Las Vegas
Strip tonight Orko mana 8 news now
Thank You Orko the governor also
confirming there will be a special
session soon where lawmakers will meet
to figure out the state budget which has
been of course hit hard by the pandemic
he also says an announcement will be
made soon in the moratorium on evictions
in foreclosures meaning we will learn
whether that will expire soon